hello and welcome to week one of ox log
the blogging series where I sign and
talk about my life is II undergraduate
University of Oxford ah I should have
thought that sentence out more now I'm
actually cheating a little bit because
these videos gone Sunday today is not
Sunday today it's actually Saturday
however tonight is some Pierce College
bull so tomorrow I am NOT going to be
very capable of doing very much those
are very Oxford thing and I don't really
have time to talk about them properly in
this video so what I'm probably gonna do
is I'm gonna be taking my camera around
some people and I'll probably do a
separate video about that so what I've
been up to this week
well in terms of work this Monday I
handed in my master's project and that
was incredibly stressful when it comes
to publications and particularly
important ones like this and this was a
large part of my degree I'm an absolute
perfectionist you know I have to make
sure that the spelling is perfect the
grammar is perfect the figures are as
clear as they can be now Jamie's
mentioning exam schools in one of his
videos because it's used for in addition
to exams hence the name lectures
particularly philosophy lectures I think
you're held there and handing in formal
work and it's an absolutely beautiful
building but because I had that in my
project on Monday I have been slowly
recuperating from the vast energy
expenditure that took place in getting
it to be perfect I hope by the time
submitted so a lot this week has been
spent just trying to draw breath before
I really launch myself into a vision for
exams I need this time to take a breath
I think it's important when you're
studying to realize when you're
exhausted
and you need to just rest for a little
bit because it's gonna mean in the long
run you do more work the bits of work
which I have been doing however have
been in outer physics we've got the last
lecture course of the entire year which
is advanced geophysical fluid dynamics
which is basically looking at how fluids
behave on a surface of the earth which
is a rotating system which is where you
get effects like the Coriolis effect
which equities hold and also a slightly
reduced gravity because the earth
spinning produces the centripetal
acceleration in theoretical physics I
had a promise sheet which I hands it in
over the Easter vacation which was on
stochastic processes now have the class
on that on Tuesday a stochastic process
is basically any physical process where
you introduce a random number so an
example of that is if you're looking
at the Brownian motion of a pollen
particle for example suspended in water
you can model the equation of motion of
that pollen grain so where it isn't as a
function of time by the viscosity of the
fluid which slows down any motion it has
and also this random term the stochastic
term which models molecules bouncing
into the pollen grain and jiggling about
other than that though like I say been
trying to take a little bit of downtime
and recuperate before the inevitable
revision starts part of that was I went
to see I'm a three on it when it came
out which was if you haven't seen it
good but not as good as the Avengers
befell that could be said of most films
and the meat was brightened up and
somewhat related now by the arrival of
this so this is the oxford unions turn
card now each products plane goes with
Union is
so most universities in the UK have
student unions they're the kind of
government I guess of the student
population they represent their
interests to the University and
coordinate with other universities on a
national level
now Oxford does have awesome university
student Lee not as easy for sure but
most of the functions that fulfill by
other universities students are
fulfilled by the junior common rooms in
each college and then those junior
common rooms send their presidents to
meet President's Committee which is
positive ozzie in addition to the option
University Students Union you also have
the Oxford Union which isn't anything to
do with that procedure but people seem
to think that the two are related the
Oxford Union is a debating society and
in fact it's probably the world's most
prestigious debating society most of
what they do is focused around getting
in people from the outside to discuss
issues of the day now they will do a
weekly debates which are advertised in
this so for example the debate which is
happening in a third week is this house
remembers New Labour fondly and it will
give you the profiles of all the people
who are speaking for and against however
the most students University that's not
what the Union is exciting because in
addition to these debates the Union also
gets in speakers just come in and talk
about either some work that they've done
or basically just come in and do a Q&A
session so one which people lock their
books ask about
haan matter this Spanish my Villa
Baroness tanni grey-thompson nate silver
the guy who predicted prevent all the US
elections and the one which I am frankly
geeking out about like I've never geeked
out about anything before joss whedon
but that's about it for this week I've
seen spending a lot of this week asleep
trying to recover so there's not all
that much to talk about last but not
least Jamie you're back we need to see
you what you up to this term if you
don't have exams or anything to worry
about
look forward to hearing about it in your
next vlog which I will see on Thursday